[Applause]
lots of mysteries
happy
thursday my favorite thursday buddies
it's a very very special night tonight
that's right it's time for
[Music]
the gutfeld international feminist
awards
yes it's the very first gutfeld
international feminist awards in which
we honor those we feel have done the
most for women
but unlike the oscars we're going to
keep it short just like me
so tonight we just have one winner and
do you know who that is
the first gutfeld international feminist
award goes to
[Music]
oh this is so embarrassing i had no idea
such a surprise i don't even know who to
thank at this point and i don't even
have anything prepared to say
except for the monologue which i wrote
so i could give myself an award
i never win anything
now i never thought of myself as a
feminist probably because i could never
grow a mustache
oh sexes
let's see that's terrible stuff and you
shouldn't laugh
but also how could i be a feminist i
admire chivalry i'm not angry and i've
yet to burn a bra
well not intentionally anyway once when
i was 17 and drunk i passed out with a
cigarette in my mouth while wearing one
of my sisters
burned down the entire convent
but in this crazy time it seems like
it's time for someone to take the lead
in defending women since the feminist
groups have gone awol so ladies follow
me if i don't ask for directions along
the way that's just how dudes roll
so allow me to mansplain there's not so
much a war on women it's more like a
persistent erosion it's creeping into
science language courtrooms restrooms
sports and the streets where you work
and you know it's a problem when leading
female achievers can no longer tell you
what a woman or what a man is
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
you've referred to people with a
capacity for pregnancy
would that be women
many women cis women have the capacity
for pregnancy many cis women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy
there are also trans men who are capable
of pregnancy as well as non-binary
people who are capable of pregnancy so
your view is is that the core of this
this right then is about what
so
i want to recognize that your line of
questioning um is transphobic
and it opens up trans people to violence
i was hoping that you could define what
a woman is for us in this committee
hearing i am a woman that's how i
identify okay but i wonder however if in
part the reason that you're asking a
question is that you're trying to
suggest that people i'm simply asking
the question and i simply want an answer
[Laughter]
as we say around the gynecologist's
office ain't that a kick in the nuts
now
now these are questions anyone could
answer two or three years ago hell these
are questions a two or three year old
could answer period but science is now
secondary to politics it's no longer
about biology it's about inventing a
language the far-left version of pig
latin and who controls the language
controls the body according to our most
prominent legal minds a man can be a
woman a man can in fact do anything a
woman can do just a few years ago if a
guy said that alone he'd be pelted with
eggs now apparently he's capable of
producing them
and if you disagree you are fomenting
hypothetical violence
as real violence real violence pays a
visit to biological women
this homeless man ran up
he had something in his hand and he just
like looked at me with some pretty
hateful eyes
and as i turned to go tell my friend
i think something's wrong with him and i
think he's going to hit a car
before i knew it a big
metal bolt
like pipe
hit me
right here here i just it happened so
fast
for the past year we saw a case after
case of women being attacked by deranged
men hitting them with pipes pushing them
downstairs shoving them in front of
subways and if you're a woman in new
york you might get all three before
lunchtime
again no feminist groups pipe up i'd say
they have no balls but in all honesty
haven't checked
you never know but i guess it's better
to excuse deranged male felons than
decide with law enforcement and even if
the perp is arrested god help you thanks
to absurd bail reform abusers walk in
and out before the blood on their hands
is dry and some revisit their previous
female victims which is ignored by
progressive loons like lada george
gascon who plans to disband a group of
victim advocates and prosecutors who
notify the victims about their
assailants parole hearings that means
when your rapist is up for parole you
won't be the first but probably the last
person to know
again where are the feminists they
refuse to take the field and speaking of
the white house just announced new title
ix rules which would sweep gender
identity into the law's protections and
strengthen protections for those who
face discrimination based on sexual
orientation or gender identity
so who is this meant to protect
take a guess i find that funny because
that's like what i'm getting beat up
about the most is like you're beating
little kids and little girls i didn't
intend to do that like i just
this was the first competition that i've
been to that i actually wanted to win
i'm not going to go there and be like
i'll go easy on them because they're
kids i try to focus on my swimming
what i need to do to get ready for my
races
and just try to block out everything
else
course when female athletes complain
about losing their spot to someone
wearing a jock strap and who has the
lung capacity of a blue whale
they're called transphobic so enjoy your
second third and fourth place trophies
girls never mind when leah thomas
competed on penn's men's team she was
the 505th best swimmer in the country
now against women she's in the top 10.
so that's like comparing apples to
oranges or our ratings to cnns
i can't resist i'm sorry
i'm so shallow it's funny how this only
benefits male to female trans not a lot
of females who became males are winning
at sports which may be another form of
sexism again where are the feminist
groups are they okay with girl athletes
getting crushed by athletes with a penis
and the muscle density of a pit bull
with a planet fitness membership
one athlete who just got a medal of
honor says if it bothers you to lose to
a trans woman then you should skip
sports and this is spoken like an
athlete who's used to losing to males
after all her team got shellacked by 15
year old high school boys
so where do you turn if you're a girl
who identifies as a girl and wants to
play against other girls well don't
expect rapido to save you a seat on the
bench
so it's kind of sad to watch strong
women do nothing to stop this trend
while men like me
do everything
you know i could go on and on but really
that's something a woman would do am i
right
[Applause]
welcome today
it's not just his accent he really is
smarter than you fox news contributor
and associate editor of the spectator
douglas murray
[Music]
and she's so smart her iq comes with a
comma deputy opinion editor red newsweek
and author of the new book bad news how
woke media is undermining democracy
under sargon
she's like clorox wipes white thin and
99 alcohol fox news contributor cat tip
and he told the big and tall store to
get bigger and taller
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion
tyrus
[Applause]
watch i go to you first because you are
a female you are a female by choice or
by biology
i don't know god made me that way so i'm
kind of stuck with it either way but you
know what that doesn't matter anymore
we could change that i have a room
we've got a home depot around the corner
put some stuff together um do you feel
that women are under attack
have i put together a persuasive
argument
yes or is it biology this is what i
think happened
for a long time and i'm very curious
what you think about this because i'm
coming from the left i think for a long
time the left was at the forefront of
very important civil rights issues like
gay rights equality for women equality
for black americans a lot of really
important struggles the left was on the
right side of those pushing them forward
and the thing that happened recently is
they won right they won on all those
fronts there is no longer a partisan
divide on any of those issues
so that became a problem for the left
because you can no longer go to your
park slope dinner party and win by
saying i don't think cops should be
beating up black people or i think women
should be treated equally in the
workplace because even republicans now
think that right yeah so they needed to
push the goal post and what they did was
they pushed it to a place that is just
totally counter-intuitive where it's now
dr king's vision is now considered
racist that's how you win at the park
slope theater party right right it's now
like it's not enough to say women
deserve equal rights you have to say
that there's no difference between men
and women they had to move the goal post
to this place where it's actually even
alienating lefties like me and like a
lot of other people
well put you know douglas in england
there's been you know often a lot of
history of gender confusion
[Laughter]
how long were you there for
not long enough i'm afraid
but you know
do you feel that this is more about the
fact that like they've run into this
brick wall of science
and if in it and it's like science is
keeping them from achieving this so they
have to kind of almost remake the
linguistics
they are trying to get around science
which is never a great thing to try to
get around yeah they're trying to get
around all facts as well that's also
going to be a problem at some point uh i
i'm not coming uh from the left of
course um and uh
but i can say with some confidence that
one of the great pleasures of our time
is seeing this snake heat its own tail
yeah i don't know if you saw
this week apart from that that weird uh
that berkeley professor uh berkeley
splaining to senator hawley um about how
uh and she said she said uh uh
non-binary people can uh can be pregnant
if they're women yes um
uh trans men can also become a pregnant
if they're women right um and of course
women can because cis women can become
pregnant uh but but but also this week
we saw rasheeda talib the the the
brilliant congresswoman
make a really important intervention she
said she said that the new york times is
busily killing trans people and should
stop saying anything about trans because
the new york times accidentally maybe
ran one story a little while ago looking
honestly at the trans issue and so the
congresswoman is like no we've got to
stop it new york times you're killing
people now so i can i sit back and i
watch anything you know the new york
times has become a transphobic rag
this thing must be nearing a conclusion
right yeah yeah
definitely
eating the tail
it's also confusing cat this being a
feminist because i consider you a
feminist right yeah i don't hate myself
well no no i i don't hate myself because
i'm a woman yeah yeah there you go you
hate yourself yeah for other reasons
i'm
curious about pregnant men who
impregnates them
wasn't me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
not getting me on that one
[Laughter]
it's okay no it's i understand
um well the penis havers yes
exactly
good answer right see i'm not cancelled
because you just say something really
reasonable like the penis haver
impregnates the uterus have her and
that's just how
that's how we all talk what that's you
actually solve the problem yeah there
you go
no that's exactly what you say yeah yes
that's fantastic yeah i sure am yeah
you don't get this
you know what
i almost feel like sharing my award with
you but
yeah they'll never let me share these
things on fox and friends
[Laughter]
tyrus uh last word you know as a yeah as
an athlete as a wrestler have you ever
considered wrestling with like you know
children just to win like that
like the skateboard like that
you saw the male to female skateboarder
who has all his stuff intact and still
beating up beating on skateboarders you
know uh i've been pretty successful
because most of the grown adults i get
in the ring with look like children
against me so i don't
really have to punch down
and i think
regardless of this individual's
perception of themselves or who they had
done you're an adult
and you were competing against
adolescent
girls
at least no one interviewed them so i'm
assuming it was girls but 13 14 year old
girl girls
and not only did you beat them soundly
you then bragged about it they took
their money and took their money uh
there's something wrong with that as you
as an individual even if i was even if
there was a term let's say there was a
tournament tomorrow
for the
super world wrestling
championship of the universe and i
stepped across the ring and there was a
toddler on the other side
he's going to win that night because i'm
not going to wrestle him yeah yeah you
know because there's no there's a
certain honor in that why would you want
to be with children but we live in a
time where it's about me
you know it's not it has anything to do
with groups or anything it's it's me and
everyone should know me and i'm special
and i'm different and i everything's
done by feelings so you can't argue
feelings she felt like she should win so
we should all understand and if you uh
disagree with me you're actually
creating a climate of violence yes
towards me you could you could which is
woke for you hurt my feelings yes yes
yeah all right
[Applause]
all right we got to move on that was a
great so thank you everybody for the
award thank you for the
you're uh i thank you um i'd like to
thank the academy of feminists hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else